as a teenager growing up in Greenwich
Village in the late 1960s Stephen Heller
improbably became the art director of
pioneering alternative Publications such
as the New York Free Press screw
magazine and the East Village other
before eventually going on to work at
the New York Times and teaching at the
School of Visual Arts for decades he
Chronicles his youthful Misadventures in
growing up underground A Memoir of
countercultural New York in November
Heller spoke at the recent Speakeasy a
monthly unscripted conversation with
outspoken Defenders of free think again
heterodoxy in an age of cancer culture
and thought police he regaled the
Manhattan audience with Tales of arrests
on obscenity charges how design and
Aesthetics can supercharge the meaning
of words and pictures
and why so many in the counterculture
adopted exactly the same uniform of
alienation in the name of individuals
[Music]
well uh ladies and gentlemen I want to
thank you very much for coming out to
the most recent
reason Speak Easy
today we are talking with Stephen Heller
the legendary art director and graphic
designer and author of The phenomenal
new book growing up underground uh A
Memoir of counterculture New York
Steve started out in the late 60s as a
teenager working at bleeding edge
alternative Outlets like the New York
Free Press and screw magazine of course
before becoming the art director at the
New York Times op-ed page for a bit and
for the book review section for many
many years a longtime faculty member at
the School of Visual Arts Steve brings
in a reverent and uniquely knowledgeable
position perspective to discussions of
how alternative and establishment
Publications influence social and
cultural change a fierce defender of
free speech in the First Amendment he
didn't just witness the past half
century of boundary busting changes to
Media uh he helped make it all jump off
the page and grab our attention uh Steve
Heller thanks for talking at the reason
Speakeasy thanks for inviting me all
right so let's start with the Memoir uh
which also I will be sending all of you
a uh discount code where you if you
order it from the publisher from
Princeton architectural press uh you can
get 20 off so that's real savings in
this inflation lots of gratitude from me
yes
um but it's a fantastic
uh personal story but it's also a story
about a particular time and place can
you what's the kind of uh elevator pitch
for your Memoir the elevator pitch is I
had 10 good years
and uh
I kept telling stories about them and at
a certain point I since I've I've
written or edited 200 books or so
I thought it was time to uh
get my story on the page
and uh various people were encouraging
me to do it and
um
I wanted to kind of
cluster the the years together how it's
possible
to
get somewhere without going to college
and still be part of the cultural scene
and
um
and I like to tell stories so
essentially that's it there was no
elevator pitch there was just calling up
the editor and saying I have a memoir
that connects me to graphic design yeah
and since they published graphic design
books it happened so the 10 good years
start what what year did that start in
1966 I was 16. so set the uh stage
because you grew up in Manhattan I grew
up in a small town in Manhattan
Stuyvesant town
so what uh what was 1966 New York like I
know there's a couple of other people
who uh were here at the same time tell
us those of us who uh don't remember or
were well 1966 you could drive a bus
through what uh the Washington Monument
the
Washington Square the arch Arch Square
yeah
um
which was you know a big thing because
if you were in the path of a bus they
didn't stop
um
Dylan was just coming on the radio with
positively Fourth Street and uh
there was a
a kind of anticipation of something
happening the Vietnam War was heating up
uh there were groups that were
founded
to protest the war
civil rights in New York was actually
beginning to start happening as a
movement
um hippie culture was gradually
taking over the East Village or what we
used to call the Lower East Side
and uh music was making a a major Splash
uh Phil Maurice the Anderson theater The
Electric Circus uh the New York Academy
of Music where I co-produced with one of
my the newspapers I was with oldies
shows at a 200 2 500 seat theater what
was an oldie show in 1966 what were you
uh doo-wop groups yeah so like from the
late from the late 50s
what Fats Domino uh Lloyd Price
you sell Vikings things like something
was emerging
um you know why
um what you know you're 16 in 1966 so
you were born this is the math brain of
a of an English major so you were born
in 1950 yep
um yeah why why was the music bursting
why what what was in the air or the
water that well things happened what was
in the air was the Beatles
and just
growing from 14 to 16.
I had gone to Sweden for a couple of
months while my my parents traveled all
over the world and they were going to
Russia on a sightseeing tour and they
you used to leave me at home they never
invited me
uh still pissed
um
but this time they sent me with a friend
to Sweden who was Swedish and Sweden's
youth culture was considerably more
advanced
as was England's than what was going on
in the United States the Beat Generation
had come to an end and there was this
transitionary period between beat and
hippie
uh exemplified by people like Ed Sanders
and a group called The thugs
which also had a bookstore uh down in
the PSI bookstore was Ed Sanders book
Bookshop and he ran a magazine called
[ __ ] you a journal of the Arts a journal
of the Arts uh the East Village other
had begun and it was around Tompkins
Square
and so when I was 15
I ventured out of my uh Little Town
Stuyvesant town across 14th Street to
Avenue A's B and C
uh Alphabet City and uh there was
a mixture of junkies and hippies
it was not a safe place to be but at the
same time there was an incursion of
younger people who are looking for cheap
places to live uh nobody had locks on
their doors because the junkies would
get in anyway
so one of my close friends my mentor who
I write about in the book had an
apartment where he just left the door
and window open so that they could come
in take what they needed and leave
being born middle class and a little
bougie in stuyvesantown I thought that
was not the right thing to do but he was
he came from elsewhere outside of New
York and he became friends with a lot of
these
uh
gang kids
you kind in the book you talk about kind
of escaping in a way it's kind of the
last gasp of straight America right of
of pre
Technicolor 60s America what was the
school you went to and you know your
your lovely hair that's in the on your
cover photo was shorn off what tell that
story and what did that signify well
just tell that story I have to first say
that when I was
uh 11 and a half I was taken to NYU to
be tested and I was given a
uh
t-a-t test
uh thematic at perception test
and
it unlike a raw shock test it's not
about interpretation it's about
narrative
and they show you pictures very detailed
uh
black and white pictures of scenes that
are happening and apparently they put
certain items in the picture that are
supposed to trigger a response well I
saw a picture of a guy with his hand
over his head
and behind him was a naked woman in bed
looked like she had been strangled
now this isn't a kind of picture you
show to an 11 and a half year old
because I couldn't stop laughing
uh and the grad student who was
conducting the test
couldn't stop writing notes in his
yellow pad
and
it turned out that test sealed my fate
to go to boys school
because I was too precocious when all I
was was naive and young and stupid
so I went to a boys prep school that was
attached to the YMCA up in uh
the 60s on the west side near the park
called McBurney
and the first year was okay because I
kind of bought into
the Conformity that they had you we wore
uniforms a joint sports teams they the
the Thematic aptitude testers or
the whole barrage of tests suggested I
needed physical activity and to go into
sports other otherwise I would turn out
to be a serial killer or something
so
um
I went to this school I bought into
their thing and then that's when I went
to Sweden for a while when I came back I
was radicalized had lived with a
communist family among other families
and I just saw this different world
uh I even changed my name uh to what it
is now
and uh when I went back to the school
there was a uh a dean of discipline
and he would measure people's hair when
you walked in for the first Bell
and at my hair even though I had trimmed
it was still pretty long
and so he sent me to a barber for a cut
three times and each time I came back it
wasn't short enough
so punitively he sent me to the YMCA
Barber and he and the barber and the gym
teacher stood around while they shorned
all my hair off and I looked kind of
like I do now
um
that just sent me into a
psychological
downturn
I went home I was
truly depressed my parents sympathized
but my mother had never liked
my hairstyles and was very controlling
about it or tried to be and their
solution was to get me a hat
but
I had an uncle who said if I didn't go
into some sort of therapy
I would probably break down
the way I felt and I felt my whole
individuality was taken away from me
even though I was wearing what an
educator later called a uniform of
alienation
um but I preferred the uniform with long
hair and Beads to uh
no hair and uh a varsity letter sweater
um so that kind of just threw me into a
tizzy and I started drawing pictures
very
uh
disturbing pictures that my therapist
really fell in love with because I was a
textbook study for her
uh and those pictures ended up getting
me into the underground press
because I sold some to different Outlets
and uh
it also got me out of the school uh my
father who
we didn't agree on the war issues and
other aspects of patriotism but he was
kind enough to go
further than he had to to get me out of
that environment and put me in a
progressive school called Walden
uh where teachers were called by their
first names and you could wear anything
you wanted and you could express
yourself
and uh it changed my life considerably
what do you
um what do you why did the why did the
boomer generation become
individualists
um you know it on mass you know
obviously there's a lot of
contradictions here but
you know you were raised by people who
were the early Boomers were raised by
people who had grown up Lucky to you
know survive the depression World War II
oftentimes and then kind of moved into a
a large-scale
um you know level of middle class wealth
or Rising wealth but they you know
typically your parents my parents they
lived conformist Lives why did their
children become these monsters who were
wearing long hair and love beads well I
think it's different for different
cultures we lived in New York City
you're
folks were in Hell's Kitchen my folks
were in Stuyvesant town
living in New York City you're a
different breed it's an island off of
America
even though my parents were conformists
they were Jews so that they were
discriminated against
they were the children of immigrants so
that they had to succeed because that's
what their parents wanted them to be and
do
and uh
while they were liberal enough not to
impose too many restrictions
uh it's all contextual I felt that I was
being confined by their
uh
their own history
you know if I didn't go to college I
would be a a failure
if uh I didn't get good grades I
wouldn't be able to go to college it was
a chain reaction
uh
you know most people who lived in New
York and I think in a middle class
environment
uh rebelled against the middle class
environment that it felt privileged on
one hand
and not privileged enough on the other
hand
and I also and I think this is also true
for Native New Yorker kids
who were within that milieu
uh I knew a lot of kids whose parents
were famous
I knew a lot of kids who went into show
business I wanted to be in an actor so I
went on auditions
uh many of my friends went to
professional Children's School
many of them ended up as druggies and
all sorts of things I
somehow managed to avoid drugs of any
kind including grass
except now I use CBD on my legs because
I have arthritis
um but
I think
when you have too little you Rebel and
when you have too much you Rebel
and even when you have just enough
uh
my father and I would argue over
certain issues of politics but at the
same time he never voted the Democratic
party he voted the liberal line
which I don't even think you can do
anymore
uh my mother hated the way my hair
looked before I started growing it out
when I had a pompadour and a duck's ass
and uh
she hated it when it was long and was
embarrassed by it
in in that seam of the 60s you know
where 66 so it's not
you know it's not quite the 60s but it's
clearly not the 50s anymore did you and
in New York and you're talking about a
place like Tompkins Square
um or you know even uh I guess
Washington Square by that point was
there a sense that the like one version
of the city or one version of the
country was dying and something new was
being born or was it
but it was there something beautiful
like in you know in the mushroom that
was Tompkins Square Park where it's a
bunch of hippies and a bunch of you know
drug addicts and muggers and that's
that's what was good or was it that this
was the soil in which something new was
coming well I really had no sense of
that I just had the sense that
there was something that I saw
in a different country that made me want
to be like them
uh uh coming back to New York I had to
disguise myself
uh I had the long hair and all that and
in order to get out of Stuyvesant Town
I'd have to put it under my collars or
pull it back in a ponytail and hide the
ponytail because literally people would
come up to me and start pulling on the
hair
I mean there was this real dichotomy
between
an alternate culture and what seemed to
be the mainstream culture
and just by virtue of
trying to walk from A to B literally A
to B
Avenue
B I had to become a different person
yeah and is it at all ironic uh Sweden
when people think of Conformity like all
sweets think the same they all look the
same they're all named Lars and
you know
I didn't meet any lars's okay although
my godson who I haven't seen in 50 years
is named Lars
well maybe it's time to get in touch
with him
um talk about the Publications that
started coming out what was what was
going on where there was this profusion
of alternative media you know in in the
mid to late 60s obviously uh uh
alternative newspapers The Village Voice
was founded in the mid 50s right so you
know you were you mentioned the East
Village other what was that and where
was the energy you know that was driving
that kind of publication well there was
a Bohemian culture
and there was a Greenwich Village that
was straight and narrow and it was
represented by the Villager
so the Village Voice was the alternative
to that it was uh mailer
um
what's his name from other scenes
John Wilcock and one other partner
not hentoff yeah thank you
and Ned Fancher
um and so there was the beginning of
this
bohemian-ness Jules Pfeiffer was my hero
I later became a friend and a editor on
one of his books
um
there was a need to break away from a
generation and it it was like the old
left and the new left
lots of the old left became part of the
Irving Crystal commentary crowd and
turned right I think it was just an
inevitable wave that kind of took over
the same way you know there was a split
in the Communist Party between those who
believed in the non-aggression pact with
Germany and those who couldn't tolerate
it there was something going on and I'm
not even sure what it is at that time in
1965-66 but there were representatives
of a different mindset and I think for
me it was governed by television
you know when I saw uh
Hugh Hefner's late night show and he
would have Lenny Bruce on it that seemed
so different than watching uh Red
Skelton
and
Ed Sullivan and there was just this
cultural wave that kind of moved through
TV despite itself
was the counterculture at that point or
as you were experiencing was it a
self-conscious you know it's a Counter
Culture it was you know the opposite
right of uh you know Lenny Bruce is the
opposite of a Red Skelton or something
like that where were you conscious of
that as like whatever they are doing I'm
going to do the opposite and that will
make sense
well yeah it's it's uh
I I'm the enemy of there's a phrase that
I used to use
I support anything that the enemy
opposes and I oppose anything that the
enemy supports jinzai Mao
and it was just a kind of
sound you know
uh I used to wear a button that somebody
just found for me
called enemy as a state
and I remember my parents getting all
freaked out when they saw it you know
that somehow I would be uh
busted for it you know they came out of
McCarthy McCarthy was
an era that uh changed a lot of people's
lives for the worst and caused other
people to
change their lives and hide
uh just this you know names changed to
avoid being considered a Jew or a
Catholic or whatever
um let's talk about some of the
characters in your book
um you you kind of go through and throw
out any ones that I don't mention but
um uh I guess let's start with uh Al
Goldstein
um because Al Goldstein is somebody who
uh well who was Al Goldstein well first
of all does anybody know who Al
Goldstein was
okay Al Goldstein was
a dirty or Lenny Bruce
and even less funny
now quite honestly he was funny as hell
I met Al Goldstein when I was 17 years
old
uh he had been working for
um
a company that produced National
Enquirer type newspapers they were all
about blood and guts
murder and sexuality not sexuality I'm
sorry murder and crime
they wouldn't touch sex they thought
that was dirty but uh ice pick murders
were just fine and dandy and Goldstein
used to write stories for them
where he'd put all our names in it so I
must have ice picked about two or three
people in my time
um he found that to be total hypocrisy
he was a very complicated person he was
a industrial spy for the Bendix
Corporation and that's how we met he
came into the office of the New York
Free Press and he wanted to whistle blow
and he wrote a story that I did a cover
for
I was an industrial spy
two-part series
uh and that's what was the Bendix
Corporation the Bendix Corporation was
some sort of War material Corporation a
chemical corporation that produced
stuff that was used during the Vietnam
war whether it was Napalm or some sort
of Machinery I don't remember
um
but he was
uh
task to find Secrets before that he was
a
Street photographer
he actually worked with a
[Music]
who is the guy Mr and Mrs America and
all the ships at sea
Edward Walter Winchell thank you he was
an assistant I'm gonna have to have you
stand next to me
he was an assistant to him
monitoring the police bands
um oh so he would go out whenever there
was some kind of terrible accident yeah
kind of like Ouija yeah and his father
was that also for the New York mirror
so he had this strange upbringing he
in the book I
recount that when he was younger he was
a bed wetter and he was overweight and
his mother took him to a doctor and he
later found out she was having an affair
with the doctor and
he just was totally messed up but he was
totally messed up with a a great sense
of humor
and it's it's as if you made a
Frankenstein's monster by taking a
libido
taking self-pity and self-effacement
and throwing it all together with other
personality flaws and
deficits and you come up with
a guy who was really basically a a
comedian
who
foreign
stuff
and with an editor he could have been a
really funny writer
who had this brilliant idea to kind of
commercialize sex to say Playboy has
become too tame Esquire gave sex up uh
the men's magazines
uh were just bad copies of Playboy
Escapade and the like
and he he went down and dirty and
started a sex paper which was called
screw which was called Screw The Sex
review I know when I started reading I
guess the Village Voice in the 70s the
you know when they would show porno ads
they would always say like you know four
stars and they could they wouldn't write
screw they would write Al goldstein's
back because even though right he had
something called the peter meter yeah so
they'd do four Peters or two or whatever
um so what was Al Goldstein doing hiring
a 17 year old kid to be his art director
I happened to be there
I left High School graduated
somewhere there's a diploma
and I I was encouraged by an art teacher
at Walden who seemed to have the same
Cloud over his head as I had over mine
and he encouraged me to take my work
around and I got a gig at an underground
paper called The Avatar where they used
a number of my drawings which
were mostly Christ figures with uh
long hair beards and no genitals
and they were doing christ-like things
like being
crucified
which seemed like an interesting thing
to draw
so like Jesus you were another Jew with
the Jesus complex
I was uh
I I didn't have a Jesus complex I
figured I felt Jesus had a Heller
complex
um and I guess it's time to point out
that in the book I uh you reproduce that
thematic apprecession test photo or
drawing that started it all and it's a
perfectly happy couple there it's I'm
joking yeah
um so what um you know uh what did you
do for uh the first screw then
well screw is being
founded at our type setting machine
our managing editor was also our
typesetter
and he and Al would go over his copy as
it came off it was called an mtst IBM
selectric system used the the round
balls that the IBM selectric typewriters
used to use but it was run by a magnetic
tape
and uh they just started talking my
office was adjacent to
the typesetting machine
and uh
I didn't know what they were talking
about and then
I think it was Jim Buckley who he was
talking to stuck his head in my office
and said you want to paste up a magazine
and I said sure because I didn't know
what I was doing anyway at the Free
Press I had gotten that job on the sly
and uh I did the first issue of screw
which is in one of those slides we'll
show those in a second uh talk a little
bit about the Free Press the the New
York Free Press what was it free of
it was free of uh hard news
uh it was actually the the local Village
Voice at one point it was the West Side
news
and the person who became the publisher
took it over from the people who owned
the West Side news changed the name
hired a legitimate editor who was also a
bartender at the 55 which is next to the
stone wall this was before the Stonewall
happened
and uh he was editor of Arts magazine
but uh something happened and he was no
longer editor of Arts magazine so he was
kind of like
an interesting character he looked a lot
like Ernest Hemingway he was older than
the rest of us but older than just meant
he was in his 30s
and he had a a a newsy intuition so he
wanted to make a paper that
was a muckraking journal he wanted two
stories that weren't being covered by
the New York Times
he would have been very happy doing the
Pentagon papers
but instead he did local news that
didn't make it into the metro section
and some of it was for real
and some of it
I'm sure the writers made up
a lot of the fake news that went into
these Publications turned out to be true
which was the irony I mean can you give
an an example of that well Nixon was
once he came into office was
attacked
on a regular basis for things that were
speculative you know his incursion into
Cambodia and things like that and what
was going on with the CIA on campuses
and these were things that weren't being
proven in
Publications like the New York Times but
there were Publications like ramparts
and Evergreen where they were in fact
covering these stories and the Free
Press wanted to cover
similar stories and if they didn't have
the story they would make it up well
they would make it up it wasn't as crass
as that they would piece together bits
of information like one of the uh
uh stars of the paper
uh was the guy who was the uh Mark Lane
who was the Kennedy conspiracy
theorist
and his theories were not all that out
of keeping with the truth
in the the answers haven't been found
yet but he was certainly right to
question he was right to question them
but also we had on our uh
as a contributing editor Eric Bentley
who ran who was the BREC translator and
he ran a club called the DMZ Uptown uh
Gregory Badcock was our art critic and
he was pretty uh important for
contemporary art Roger Greenspun who was
also a film critic later at the times
did you have a sense of anything being
possible or I mean because you know and
part of the book it's almost like you
would go out on a random walk and you
would stumble across somebody who was
just either living a bizarre lifestyle
or starting something that would become
meaningful everybody
could do anything it was I mean
there's a section in the book where I
talk about our dealings with the
mob
um I was so young I didn't know to be
afraid of these guys who are our
Distributors basically and there's the
distributor for uh for screw map there
were the Distributors for all the
underground papers and then screw
published uh uh magazine for a while
called the mobster time we published
mobster times I was a co-publisher of
that
but that was being distributed by the
mob no that was being distributed by
Curtis which distributed uh Saturday
evening post
but they were going downhill at the time
and they needed some other properties
and they took on our mobster times
thinking that
they wouldn't have to spend much money
because they weren't going to invest
much but it would be a publication that
would turn out to be something like the
National Lampoon
they were wrong
uh and they ultimately folded us
but uh the mobster times was supposed to
be
kind of an ironic title it dealt with
major criminals like J Edgar Hoover
uh while it also dealt with uh
we had a two-part uh series with gay
talise talking about the mob
so there were there was a certain
legitimacy at least what we thought was
legitimate and there was a certain
fantasy that we how important to the
broad kind of alternative uh media world
or the or the world of the 60s that was
merging how how important was irony
irony was the
the basis for everything it was
the crust of the pie and uh
you know Goldstein was
living his life in reality but it was
all based on irony
um when he would go out on
a date he would carry a medical bag with
him and had all these sex toys in it and
he knew that it was ridiculous
but he did it
so there was this kind of Crossing the
the line from irony into reality
and that seemed to be a big part of the
counter thing right because Eisenhower
in the 50s to simplify everything they
were not ironic they were what they said
they were no there was no irony that I
could discern I mean there was
comedy there were sitcoms there was I
Dream of Jeannie there was
Mr Ed
but you wouldn't turn to those now as
being the height of
it wasn't the Marx Brothers Mark's
brother and I guess uh Mad Magazine is
is kind of one of the active ingredients
Mad Magazine is the godhead 50s and is
deeply ironic in a in an America that is
pretty plays a pretty straight it was
very
Progressive for a time when
we were terrified of the Red Scare
I'm terrified by the Red Scare and of
course Mad Magazine had to change its
format because of uh Congressional
investigations and the comics code that
was imposed on all comics
uh that you couldn't have sex you
couldn't have violence you couldn't have
an unpatriotic messages you couldn't
have soldiers that committed
atrocities
you couldn't have a lot of things that
would make kids stay up late at night
and
need
psycho Pharmaceuticals
so uh let's uh you know and I want to go
through some of the pages that you
include in the book and just talk about
what they represent but before we do
that
um tell uh tell us briefly who Mel Lyman
was and what was your interaction with
him well Mel Lyman was a cult figure
from Boston and when you say a cult
figure you're not saying he's like uh uh
you know like a cult filmmaker he's not
a kind of thinker he actually ran he was
like Jim Jones yeah he ran a cult
somehow he had money because he had a
house in Boston as far as I know I never
went up there but he had a townhouse on
uh 15th Street off of 7th Avenue
he had followers he had a band he ran
the underground paper the avatar
he had a
charismatic following
um which is why they took my drawings my
christ-like drawings because they felt
it was consistent with his
christ-like embodiment
is that the flip side of the
individualism that was kind of pushing
up in the 60s I mean you have people who
are individuals and then it seems you
you couldn't swing a dead cat in New
York or L.A or San Francisco or anywhere
without hitting a cult and a cult leader
well that's what I meant by the uniform
of alienation
everything was somewhat conformist but
conformist to a Counter Culture so Lyman
was certainly one of those kind of
dangerous characters I mean I contrast
him to Goldstein because Goldstein never
tried to create a cult he just tried to
create an audience
and there's a difference between
followers and
an audience
but there was certainly a lot of that
going on whereas
you know Abby Hoffman and Jerry Rubin
as
iconoclastic and individualistic as they
seemed wanted people to follow them into
the breach
and you know I I
was because of my upbringing in
Stuyvesant town I think I was a little
more pragmatic than most of my
colleagues the first time I could vote I
voted for Hubert Humphrey
everybody else was voting for Peace and
Freedom and Eldritch Cleaver and uh I
knew that wasn't going to happen
and I also knew from being around my my
father and mother that Nixon was not
going to be the best thing for the
country so I always took a kind of
pragmatic approach to my undergrounding
which is kind of like I'm not a
religious Jew but I'm a cultural Jew
so I wasn't a religious hippie but I was
a cultural hippie
um let's uh who was Brad Holland and why
is he important Brett Holland is one of
the
greatest post rockwellian illustrators
in the United States
and he had worked at Hallmark cards
and wanted something better for himself
he was from Arkansas and Ohio and he was
he was you know a midwesterner who came
to New York like so many other people
did
but he answered an ad in the Village
Voice that I had put in for a magazine
that I was starting once I had two or
three months into being at the Free
Press I figured I knew everything
so I could start my own magazine I had a
friend whose father was a printer he was
also an anti-semite and a drunkard but
he had a big the full package the full
package but he also had this printing
firm and he he didn't give it to me for
free but he gave me a discount and I
used my bar mitzvah money to pay for it
uh the only thing he insisted was I
couldn't put in any political ads
he was
uh he he would have been a trump person
at this stage if he was alive
uh but I did put this magazine together
and Brad Holland answered the ad and
brought in with him this wealth of
experience which basically was my
graduate school
uh and doctoral program in graphic
design and what was the name of this
publication borrowed time it was
uh
again my youthful innocence I felt we
all lived I read a lot of uh existential
stuff at that time in Russian literature
in my bathroom
and uh I
absorbed all of these cliches of
existentialism and sart and Camus and
I wanted to make a magazine that was as
depressing
can you is Brad Holland is he still
alive yeah okay and is his journey kind
of from the Midwest or from you know
Arkansas and Ohio to New York from
Hallmark cards to Alternative press is
there is that emblematic of what was
going on in in America or for a good
chunk of it well there was a lot of it
was a magnet you know it was
uh
like some of the music
uh people came to New York looking for
another way of living
um he came to New York and he settled in
on the Lower East Side
he ended up getting work with Playboy
where he worked uh had a column a rival
Classics he worked for avant-garde
magazine for the great art director
herbalen
uh he became a regular on the op-ed page
of the New York Times
um
he was copied by
many many many people to the extent that
they kind of defused some of his work
through bad copies and some good copies
um
he has always been true to himself
uh he he taught me
not only how to do things
that I absorbed a lot by osmosis but
what to read uh
how to think
as an art director
and he wasn't a cult figure he was just
who he was and I was lucky enough to be
in his path
as uh
I was growing up I'm going to try and
grab my computer and see if I can reach
and we're going to run through some of
the the slides that you have in the book
yeah uh can you talk a little bit about
this I mean first let's start with that
New York Free Press that's an incredible
page that was an ad for a benefit that
we had so at the Fillmore East a famous
venue no longer extant what what kind of
world are we in where you know it's a
benefit with Norman mailer Charles
Mingus the fugs
well before I entered the world I didn't
have any idea who these guys were
um once I entered the world I was
introduced to them
and I found out how significant they
were in that
period of count of culture between
1949 and 1963 or four
and uh
mailer gave this
amazing talk that everybody hated
because he was more misogynistic than
anybody could have imagined and he just
stood on the stage and he confronted the
audience it was
really quite amazing to see
and I never liked mailer personally but
it was a little piece of history that
was never recorded
uh it must have been
69 or so
so uh talk about screw magazine then uh
well also let me just say something
about Charlie Mingus uh the
his wife who just passed away about a
month ago Susan Mingus
she was our advertising
uh sales person so we shared an office
together
and I didn't know who Charlie Mingus was
I wasn't a jazz person my uncle was a
very big Jazz person and started
introducing me to jazz artists records
at any rate
so I had no idea that Mingus was a
genius
he had stopped playing two years prior
to this
uh and he was courting Susan
uh who and they would constantly be at
war with each other so I became Susan
mingus's beard her name was angaro at
the time
and
Charlie would call up
Charles would call up and uh ask for her
and I would always have to say she
wasn't there and that's when I started
developing pseudonyms because he would
say who's this
and I would give a name like for some
reason I came up with John Bingham very
white bread name
um and every so often he'd come up to
the office and Susan would somehow
miraculously not be there and one time
he came up and he was just so pissed
that he couldn't reach her he put his
fist which is three times as big as mine
maybe four because I have tiny hands
like Trump
um through the wall next to my head
I was a little nervous
um this page kind of mailer Mingus
they're old though right I mean they're
they're not hippies they're no their
culture they're from the earlier the
older left yeah and then the thugs kind
of get there the fugs are there and the
thugs they're like a transitional life
form from uh beatniks into hippies
beatnix into hippies and they had they
were music a rock group and they were
called the fugs based on Norman mailer's
uh [ __ ] you because he couldn't use the
word [ __ ] yeah in the naked and the dead
and uh right there's the great Dorothy
Parker quote that when she met Norman
mailer the naked and the dead was the
Great War novel of World War II and um
she said oh you're the man who doesn't
know how to spell [ __ ] right
um screw magazine speaking of [ __ ]
what is going on with that that it looks
like a terrible magazine
it wasn't very well put together
the logo was handed to me by Goldstein
he had some friend of his do it I think
the friend
had no arms and no legs
um but
this the penis there is trying to be
ironic
um the irony comes in to
the woman holding the salami you know
it's like the train going into a tunnel
um I put the hand with the finger or
whatever is in his finger onto the
salami thinking that was would be clever
way of
putting in headlines and then at the
last minute we decided we should put a
warning label on so kids wouldn't buy it
and what happened was with this issue
they printed a few thousand and Jim and
Al distributed themselves they brought
it to all these news dealers and in
those days you had to be a veteran to be
a news dealer in New York and many of
them were disabled and quite a few of
them had no sight they were site
impaired and the cops were told to go
out and confiscate all of this stuff and
arrest some of the news dealers
just to scare them off and some of the
news dealers they arrested were blind
and that made it into the papers that
blind news dealers were being arrested
for
stuff they couldn't even they didn't
even know what was there wow
um the New York review of sex after
six issues of the free pres of the screw
um
Goldstein wanted a new logo
and uh I didn't know how to make a logo
I didn't know as you can see I didn't
know how to paste up a newspaper but I
started drawing
a logo that would never have worked
because it was too big and Goldstein
called me up at home I was living at
home and he said I've got one we're
going to use it I don't care what you're
doing he he could get nasty
and uh I left the in tears basically my
job with him he and Jim Buckley moved
out and got a an office on Union Square
and the publisher and the editor of the
Free Press and I started the New York
review of sex
as a Vengeance paper we were getting
back at so this is the First Act of
revenge porn First Act of revenge porn
yes it was funded by Grove press for the
first issue and then they saw what we
were doing and they said we don't want
any part of this
um here are two magazines that you
worked on
um uh is this the first issue of
interview
no interview existed for at least a year
before I came on board what uh what was
the interview in this iteration
interview was the same as it is now
except not as uh
extensive I mean what it was was
somebody would start writing about a
movie or two uh this issue was devoted
to Death in Venice
uh
as far as I know Warhol saw it but he
never saw the layouts before they went
to press
and uh
I worked with Bob colocello who
ended up at Vanity Fair and Glenn
O'Brien who ended up also at Vanity Fair
I guess uh here this
um how how does this Photograph kind of
describe what was going on in
the culture which by that point was kind
of synonymous with counterculture well
every uh underground political paper
like rat or the Free Press or the East
Village of the you see a little bit of
that sticking out or other scenes which
was John Wilcox publication
produced a sex paper
because
the majority of money that came into any
of these papers first were the record
companies and second were porn ads
for either porn films or classifieds for
hookers
and uh eventually
the New York Free Press gave up
passed the Baton onto the New York
review of sex
kiss belonged to the East Village other
and the four and there was one called
pleasure which is I think is there a
pleasure was rat's paper before women
took over rat the feminists ultimately
took over rat
uh
and then there were some Slicker
Publications like Evergreen review
which also had a sexual component but it
was more literary and uh and that was
published by growth that was Grove press
yeah and I attend I was the art director
of that in its last Incarnation and that
I mean among other things there was a
special issue devoted to
um Last Tango in Paris there was a
special issue devoted to last time yeah
was there a sense which was a movie that
came out uh you know that was considered
so out there it got an X rating
um I mean was there a sense that like
everything like nothing was
impermissible well
growth press started
its rise with the film I'm curious
blue
yellow yellow yep but there was also an
I'm curious blue I think but the I am
curious yellow went to the Supreme Court
and the Supreme Court then uh determined
that pornography was Community standards
so Grove won this huge case which opened
the doors to everything
television was still Sanctified and
there was no such thing as cable and the
idea of pay TV was being
tossed around
but the idea that all of this stuff
would turn into HBO was not in anybody's
consciousness
let's go through a couple others and
then we'll open it up for uh questions
there's the irony right and for those of
you who know who Milton Glaser was who
passed away two years ago he did that
logo
with the uh with the upturn with the
Peyronie's disease penis yes that we
have all learned about thanks to the
Clinton Administration but here's the
irony right that Betty Boop uh what a
cartoon character from the 30s from
Tyler sexualized became an icon to the
counterculture right and if uh we did
this today we'd probably be slapped with
a number of copyright infringements
well that's Ed Sorel
uh and as you can see there's the only
sex is coming from the tape recorder uh
presumably Richard Nixon and these are
the missing 26 or 28 minutes and that's
Judge Sarika listening to the tape
recorder the joke is he's hanging out
with BB raposo his buddy
um
let's um oh this is kusama
can you explain what the hell this is
and I'd say I'm a little bit offended I
don't know what this is but
what offends you the masks or these fact
that it's uh ends Christian Anderson yes
or you know it well it's it's Central
Park actual penises right
oh yeah
I didn't notice that uh yayoi kusama is
now considered one of the great artists
of
the 21st and 20th and late 20th 21st
century she when I knew her she was
selling us pictures of her artwork her
happenings that were orgies she was the
polka dot Queen of the world and she
made soft sculptures that looked like
potatoes and or phallic symbols and she
would hire
uh hippies mostly to put on masks or not
as the case may be and run around with
polka dots all over their bodies naked
usually in public places
and uh she provided us with so many
pictures that if I kept them I'd be rich
right now but uh
it it went to the Woody Allen joke about
the guy who thought he was a chicken why
didn't you put him in an institution
well we needed the eggs
we thought she was crazy but we needed
the pictures
um I guess uh I let's just
yeah well she lives in a mental
institution but on her own terms
she could leave whenever she wants she
leaves whenever she wants it's across
the street from her studio uh here's a
couple of uh he's Village others but
let's
um we'll go to questions in a second I
guess one of the things that I want to
ask you then is
you know what what we're seeing here and
in your book is kind of that great
weirdening of America uh where you know
suddenly you went 10 years before you
know 1960 and 1970 are kind of like
different planets
um something broke open you know a
Pandora's box of all sorts of things is
there is there an underground now or a
counterculture if there isn't the same
kind of repressive culture that you grew
up out of well I think the repressive
culture has been minimized or changed
uh there are still taboos but the
underground now are the militias and the
survivalists and the anti-semites and
the anti uh and the white supremacists
who had always been underground but
fortunately way underground but like
cicadas they come out every seven years
and the left has kind of become
ineffectual
uh
student populations are not organized we
don't have a war
that we're all fighting against
you know the idea of patriotism now is
uh
so mixed you know we're talking about
democracy as being at at risk and that's
bringing some people together at least
rhetorically
but you know next Tuesday we might not
be sitting here so happy
you know I I'm confident that America
will be just as awful after Tuesday as
it is now
um I think it could be much more awfuler
um can I ask you about sex in
contemporary culture because the 60s and
and certainly your work in underground
alternative Publications were synonymous
with sex with showing naked bodies right
orgies you know things like Last Tango
in Paris is you know still kind of a
shocking movie because of it's frankness
about sexuality that seems to have gone
missing certainly on the left you don't
hear nobody is a sexual liberationist
anymore no because it's become part of
life I mean I'm I'm still kind of
shocked by what does go on on HBO and
elsewhere
uh you know Playboy doesn't show sex
images anymore and it's not like they
became Born Again Christians it's just
it wasn't selling
uh and sex scandals are no longer
scandals they're just uh voyeuristic
entertainments
um you left this world behind and fell
into a ring of Hell known as The New
York Times can you just very briefly for
me it was The Ring Of Heaven yeah how
did that happen and what was the what's
the through line in terms of working at
alternative places and then ending up at
the New York Times which is is the
culture
the through line is knowing how to put a
newspaper together
it was as simple as that
I was hired by Lou Silverstein who was
the great redesigner of the New York
Times a terrific art director he saw in
my portfolio a whole bunch of screw
pages but they were well laid out and
the typography was great by the time I
went back to screw after going to some
other papers and learning The Craft
he hired me for that he hired me because
he was had a sense of humor
uh because he saw that I had a passion
for Publications
and you know my
highest goal in life was to work for the
New York Times
and although there are many
people who I was not very happy with
uh I mentioned one of them in the book
uh there were others who were just
terrific to be around and to learn from
and you know to be in an office and have
uh
brand name intellects walking in and
talking
candidly
I mean the times was still full of
taboos and still is full of taboos I
mean only recently did I read in the New
York or the word [ __ ]
they finally learned how to spell it
fug right right yeah it's just
pronounced oddly uh and you were at the
New York Times book review yes for
decades 30 years or so
um is it fair to say that that I mean
essentially what happened is the
counterculture you know it pushed back
against the culture and then it became
the culture I mean in terms of the
Aesthetics it's inevitable yeah I mean
when I when Rolling Stone first came out
which is another place I wanted to work
except I didn't want to go out to
California because California is going
to fall into the sea
they were doing things with photographs
that were not being done
I learned later that it was done in the
30s but silhouetting photographs and all
of a sudden the time started doing that
so the times
picked up younger designers and actually
had designers when before it didn't so
those of us who got older I mean I left
the underground because I used to hang
out at hilly Crystal's bar
I didn't drink or I or I drank very
little but I hung out there and when he
started cpgb's he took me over to show
me the place and I thought it was the
most disgusting joint I'd ever been in
particularly the bathroom so it was time
for me to get a suit and tie and
trim my hair and can I before we go to
questions
um is you know you you've kind of
described a kind of dialectical movement
of there's culture Counter Culture you
know that thesis antithesis becomes a
new synthesis is that liberating or is
that just kind of the same old same old
or is there room for something that
where the counterculture is not you know
being against the man it's saying like I
don't care what you're doing and I'm
just moving out to the frontier I'm
building Burning Man or I'm just doing
my own thing or is that is it never
really it never really well burning man
has become mainstream yeah
everything gets co-opted
and if you can be
a co-opter
um you can
somehow chop off the prefix and be an
opter an operator
Within
your frame
I mean I
if if I were still back in those days I
would be a basket case now you know
and I've
there was a reunion a few years ago of
the East Village other it's on the web
there was a an NYU project on the Lower
East Side and all of these you know I
was always the youngest or at least the
second youngest person in all of this
goings-on and the older ones
are in their 70s and 80s
and they were still hippies
there's something embarrassing about
that
all right uh let's um if you have a
question
um here uh can I come over to you
and ask you to
can you stand up Gene
yeah
well thank you for your uh for your
recollection of all nostalgic moments
for me uh older than you and I've been
in New York since 1967 uh and uh but
before I get to my question I want to
file just a couple of brief comments
that to those who to those who say that
Lenny Booth is not funny uh he was
hilarious in his day we laughed at him
in his day and I admit though he's not
funny now oh I thought he was funny I
thought he was funny yeah I know I know
I know and then and then in 196 but then
but similarly to read up to my question
uh in 1968 I wanted to file the fact I'm
reading partisan review and there's a
long excerpt from a forthcoming novel
and it's about masturbation and it's a
it's brilliant writing by Philip Roth
and it remains brilliant but it's still
a little bit sophomoric to this day but
that leads to my question ironically
perhaps the best the best reception of
uh recognition of the 1960s was that it
was that Bob Dylan was the Nobel Prize
for literature the the guy of the 60s
and the 70s wins the Nobel Prize and
Philip roethlis denied he wins and but
then my question is what what do you
think aesthetically and otherwise you've
commented a little bit was positive
about the about the the long run
influences of this time and then more
difficult what you haven't coming in
what are some of the negatives about the
long run influences of this time
thank you
well the long run influence is
personally
was that my mind was opened up and it
didn't have to be opened up by drugs I
mean Philip Roth is one of my favorite
authors Bob Dylan is one of my favorite
songwriters I'm reading his book right
now on the psychology of the Popular
Song
which actually I I'm halfway through and
I got up to Ricky Nelson
and his take on Ricky Nelson is just
marvelous
uh I think what it what the the 60s did
was open up
Horizons of
intellectual possibility entertainment
uh possibilities and and experiences uh
we still have show tunes but we also
have other kinds of plays
um yeah where you may I ask were there
Broadway musicals like
um Book of Mormon no Jeff uh of uh
um yeah well hair hair was in my late
six not perotic hair hair was that
transitional point where you wondered
whether it was being co-opted or not and
at a certain and there was laughing
which did all the Psychedelic numbers
but also took pot shots at government
policies
and
could excuse me
Monty Python but England was another
case altogether could you uh what about
the negatives are are there negative
kind of Aesthetics that came out of the
60s or a legacy of the counterculture
well I think I think the negatives are
uh
the drug culture
uh I mean I'm not against
taking recreational drugs if that's what
you want to do but I think it became too
much of a culture
uh the commune culture
was not really all that positive I know
a lot of people who went through it and
got messed up because of it
I mean what you were talking about
before not being able to throw a cat
around without hitting a cult you know a
friend a friend of mine was a
sullivanian but he was also a hippie
before he was a sullivanian so that was
the it was the kind of Gateway movement
to the Cults
and I think there's still folks who
subscribe to that
and some of them have just turned off
entirely I mean I wasn't that fond of
turn on turn off drop out I didn't think
that was the best of all slogans yeah
okay uh other questions
yes
um if you're not too happy about big
current counter cultures like militias
uh are there at least small things that
make you feel as excited as you were uh
in the 60s that make you think ah these
people still get it this gives me hope
there's a future
well I'm not I don't want to be
facetious but I really love BBC
Mysteries
I have my my life has
devolved into I can't walk very well
because I've got an arthritic leg and so
and I can't sleep very well because I
worry about the world blowing up
so instead I watch BBC
so that's become my life
that and my son and my wife
um do you worry more about the world
blowing up now than in 1968 no no it's
the same okay
no I used to dream mushroom clouds I
mean remember we had Airaid drills every
week
we are bill stuyvesantown every ground
floor was up to the seventh floor we
were on the seventh floor had fallout
shelter signs which they've still they
won't take down now there's still
thousand of them left in New York City
uh I remember the Cuban Missile Crisis
vividly
uh and now I read books about how just
one slip of the finger could have
changed everything and you see what's
going on with the people who once we
thought were comic book characters who
were not comic book characters so I'm as
I just know that you know I've got maybe
another couple of decades at most
uh but I'm worried for my my kid I'm
worried for his kids if he ever has any
uh other questions
hi Stephen I have a question
um when you were publishing
taboo things in the 60s
um did you feel
a danger of repercussion for what you
were printing
um and the reason I asked that is
because now we often talk about
cancel culture or you lose your job
because somebody is offended by what
you've printed did you did you feel a
similar danger then or was it were
basically Untouchable except maybe
polite people won't like us well it's a
great question and I can go on for hours
about it so I will uh
you have nothing to do there's nothing
good on TV tonight
um I just heard about this BBC thing
you have to get Brit box
um
I'm
when when I was I was arrested twice I
was arrested when I was 17 and I missed
Woodstock because of it and I was
arrested when I was 18 both on
pornography charges in both cases I was
taken to the tombs
and one the first case I was too young
to be put in the pens with uh the other
vagrants and drunks and criminals so I
was put in with the prostitutes and I
found that they liked me
the second time was less fun because I
was 18 so they put me in actual lock-up
other than that
I was too naive to be afraid of anything
I was I thought what we were doing could
have repercussions but not in the
immediate repercussions and certainly
not further down in my life
um I felt that this was America
and there were lawyers and there were
safeguards and
the one thing I was afraid of was going
into the army so I got many different
deferments and I was also 1A when the
lottery came and that was the thing that
scared me most
but
today I feel like much more constricted
you know when I put this book together
I felt I should limit the number of
screw images that I would show
because
people in cancel culture go back 25 30
40 50 years
to root out the enemy
and so I'm not a big fan of cancel
culture I am a big fan of the First
Amendment
do your students I mean you've been on
the faculty of the school for visual
arts or School of Visual Arts for a long
time do you feel like are your students
inhibited by that as well or have they
grown up in a world where they're not
even thinking about well it's
interesting that you ask that because
the demographic of our student body has
changed to a great extent and one of the
changes is we have a lot of Chinese
students from the People's Republic of
China who
are subject to
uh some very harsh penalties should they
be
caught doing things that they're not
supposed to do according to government
rules so
I'm all I'm very careful not to give
them assignments I teach a class on
propaganda
and I'm very careful not to give them
assignments that might cause them harm
and it's we've never proven this in
School of Visual Arts but it's been
discussed amongst faculty
in lots of different schools that there
are Chinese
uh agents
who are also students but they will
report back
so it's
we're very circumspect
then there's also the Dei stuff
that's diversity equity and inclusion
how does that affect
your artistic sensibilities it doesn't
affect my artistic sensibilities because
I don't really have artistic
sensibilities at the moment but it does
mean that we're
always
attuned to what we say and what we do
uh it it doesn't
squelch our freedoms but it makes us
more circumspect about
our actions so
simple stuff which is actually kind of
commonsensical I don't close my door
when I'm meeting with an individual
male female whatever
uh
I don't say things that I would say to
friends or in public because I don't
want to offend anybody
do you feel that you know does that is
that filtering out into the culture and
does it make it a less robust
risk-taking culture or is that a loss
that is easy to live with well I think
it's something that the right is
uh caught on to
and is
where their Counter Culture begins
our cancel culture is their meat
and uh we're not vegetarians yet not yet
um I think we're going to leave it there
I want to thank Stephen Heller the uh
the author
of most recently you're 20 first book uh
growing up underground actually there
are two others coming out next month my
God this is It's like a bodily function
you could call it that yeah
thank you so much Stephen Heller and
thank you all for coming out to the
reason Speakeasy thanks so much
[Music]